welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Timothy Snyder professor of history
at Yale University professor Schneider
teaches undergraduate and graduate
courses in modern East European
political history he is the author and
co-editor of several award-winning books
today we'll talk with Professor
Schneider about his most recent book a
critically acclaimed New York Times
bestseller entitled blood lands Europe
between Hitler and Stalin
welcome professor Schneider very glad to
be here let's begin with an overview of
your book tell us about it well this is
a book about the greatest moral and
demographic catastrophe in the history
of the West it begins from the
observation that in a very short period
of time between 1933 and 1945 in a
relatively small part of the world
between the Baltic and Black Seas
between Berlin and Moscow about 14
million people were deliberately
murdered so the question naturally
arises why I look at these territories
rather than looking at the places that
occupied them rather than looking at
just the countries the way that we've
investigated this horror previously has
always had to do with particular
political systems either Nazi Germany or
the Soviet Union or with particular
victim groups the Jews the Ukrainians
the poles the Russians what I've done it
that in this book as I've looked at the
entire territory and that all the
victims and I've looked at both of the
regimes as they crossed into the
territory and tried to investigate each
murderous policy of each of these two
regimes this subject has been the
subject of many many books you take a
little actually a very different look at
it why did you feel it was important to
write the book
well I mean one thing which is which is
which is striking is that no one has
ever made the point that I just made it
seems like a very simple point 14
million people are killed in a certain
time in place that's never been noticed
has never been noticed that of all the
killing that the Germans did during the
30s and 40s all of it was in this zone
for all practical purposes all of it of
all the killing that the Soviets did a
disproportionate amount was in this zone
and this was a zone where both the
Germans and the Soviets were present
sometimes at the same time sometimes one
right after the other
so the initial goal of the book was to
try to give a sense of the entirety of
this catastrophe another goal the book
was to try to get us out of thinking in
the channeled ways that we have that
this is just about poles or it's just
about Jews and to try to get us to
understand also it's important to
understand that the Germans and the
Soviets were interacting with each other
sometimes we read about Nazi Germany or
about Stalin Soviet Union it's about who
usually have the impression of these
things are happening on different worlds
on different planets in fact these
powers were primarily influencing the
same sets of territories in the same
sets of peoples so there hasn't actually
been a book which looked at the totality
of this catastrophe before there hasn't
been a book which looked at which looked
at it from the point of view of all of
the victim groups before and there
hasn't been a book which looked at the
two systems not in isolation but in
their actual presence in this region and
sometimes in their interactions ok let's
talk about the interactions how how did
Stalin and Hitler work together and what
was their rationale for killing these
millions and millions of people right
that's where things get a little bit
difficult because there's some simple
answers and those simple answers are
wrong so one simple answer is that
Stalin had Hitler were basically the
same when here's a lot about when here's
a lot about that especially into very
American political life they're
basically the same they're just they're
socialists or something they're the same
that answer is incorrect they were quite
different they had different ideologies
they had different visions of the future
Hitler was interested in a race war
which was going to come in the future
which would allow the Germans to create
a huge agrarian empire in the east
bereft entirely of Jews with the Slavs
reduced to a condition of slavery or
expelled Stalin was interested in a
world socialist revolution mom who's
interested a bright future for the
working class
in order to get there he was he was
willing to carry out vast policies of
coercion and territory on his own
territory so you have two rather
different views of the world two quite
different ideologies what they have in
common chiefly is territory
so the territories that Hitler wants for
his future agrarian colony in the East
are the same territories that Stalin has
to master in order to build up his own
vision of socialism in what he calls
socialism in one country so the visions
are very different where they overlap is
territory and we tend to forget about
this because territory for us is not
important unless there happens to be oil
underneath it and in the 1930s food was
for the Germans and for everyone else
roughly like what L is us but what is is
for us today back then food was a kind
of natural resource you had to try to
control territory in order to control
food because big important industrial
countries like Germany were not
self-sufficient in food so the two
regimes had these different visions and
then they begin to interact they begin
to interact most importantly at the
beginning that kind of the intellectual
level what Stalin does create the
socialism in one country this
industrialization on the scale of the
Soviet Union Hitler wants to undo
Hitler's thinking about the East is a
kind of reversal the Soviets build up
cities we shall destroy them the Soviets
create factories we will knock them down
the Soviets increase their own
population will decrease the population
of those territories by tens of millions
of people the second point of
interaction is 1939 when these two
regimes are de facto military allies
they find the thing which they can agree
upon which is that there's no purpose in
the existence of independent Poland
so they both invade Poland which is the
only important country between them in
September of 1939 they destroy it and
along the way the Soviets destroy three
other countries Estonia Latvia and
Lithuania this creates a kind of no
man's land a kind of new territory for
conquest for both the Soviets and the
Germans and this is the beginning really
the beginning of massive violence on the
German side and that's important because
the Soviets have been killing on the
scale of hundreds of thousands or
millions all the way through the 1930s
it's the war it's this point of can't
in the 19th in late in 1939 the
disruption of States in 1939 which
allows the Germans to catch up to the
Soviets so that's a very important point
of contact and then there's the final
point of contact is 1941 when the
Germans invade the Soviet Union when
they try to carry out try to execute
this policy of imperialism to colonize
the Western Soviet Union it doesn't work
but you still have polka moments of
interaction the two sides provoke each
other to do things they wouldn't have
ordinarily done conditions are worse on
both sides because the two countries are
at war precisely so in the Soviet gulag
in the Soviet system of concentration
camps these are the years when people
die in large numbers people are in the
gulag because of Stalin but they die in
large numbers because the Germans have
invaded the Soviet Union what the
Germans do in the East is a kind of
mixture of what they wanted to do this
Oviatt Union they wanted to destroy the
state starve tens of millions of people
eliminate the Jews somehow they weren't
quite sure how yet even as late as
summer 1941 and build up their own
colony what they were able to do was
kill Jews where they lived and so this
colonization project in the Soviet Union
becomes the mass murder that we then
understand as the Holocaust and you know
that is very interesting because for
instance when I think of this time
period I do think of the Holocaust and
Jews in particular and you know and
Frank hiding but the thing that struck
me in your book you write during the
years that both Stalin and Hitler were
in power more people were killed in
Ukraine than anywhere else in the blood
lands or in Europe or in the world so my
question is why don't
Westerners what why don't we really
understand that because it was a
surprise to me and and why you know how
do you explain that yeah the sad truth
is that our image of the Holocaust and
of German killing and of the whole
tragedy is complete we have we have an
image of the Holocaust we think we
understand the Holocaust but it's
actually a very small fraction of what
happened and Frank was a German Jew
German Jews were in general bourgeois
middle class people like you and me
people who might have known people in
other countries people who often escaped
about half of the German
Jews actually survived Anne Frank didn't
she represented this group which was
exceptional in fact but which we take us
typical why are they exceptional because
the German Jews are such a small small
small small percentage of Holocaust
victims in 1939 only about a quarter of
1% of the German population is of Jewish
origin the the Jews live in places like
Poland where there are three and half
million almost they live in the Soviet
Union worth even more they live in
Hungary they live in the Baltic States
these are the real populations of Jews
these are the these are the serious
historical homelands of European Jews so
the Holocaust is not primarily a tragedy
that strikes German Jews although the
tragedy of German Jews is horrible it's
primarily a tragedy that strikes the
Jews of Eastern Europe and so in order
to understand the Holocaust one has to
get beyond the image that we have of
people going on long train trips to
camps and then being killed that was
exceptional what generally happened was
that people were shot about two and a
half million people were shot very close
to where they lived in the occupied
Soviet Union or they were gassed in
facilities in Poland which were also
generally not terribly far away from
from where they lived what we have is
that is is the outer edges of the
Holocaust and we've confused it with the
whole thing and I found that very
fascinating because it's a whole new way
to look at that period of time yeah and
you ask why I mean a lot of it has to do
with what's familiar to us I think and
Frank is a much more I mean I read that
when I was her age right when she died
that's an accessible book for for
everyone
much less accessible for us I think are
the experiences of Yiddish speaking
Polish Jews or Russian speaking Soviet
Jews people who are further away perhaps
culturally but also those lands fell
behind the Iron Curtain there's a
strange way in which the memory of what
the Germans do is cut off by the Cold
War the one way to think about where the
blood lands are is that they're east of
what used to be Iron Curtain the Iron
Curtain falls at the western border of
the blood lands right after the war and
so the very places were the Germans
killed not just where the Soviets killed
but the places where the Germans killed
fall out of view they fall into the
shadow of the iron
and they become abstract and when we
built up in the 50s 60s 70s and 80s an
image of German killing it tended to be
based upon things in the West like Anne
Frank for example in hiding in the
Netherlands rather than on the East
which is my subject I'm an East European
historian that's where I could write a
book like this that's why I felt I had
to write a book like this okay let's
talk about your methodology how did you
do the research for the book well the
first thing I keep returning to this but
the first thing which is different about
this book is that it focuses on
territory it's not it's not a history of
Hitler history of Stalin it's not just a
history of the Soviet Union or of Nazi
Germany it's not just a history of
Estonia Latvia Lithuania Belarus Ukraine
Poland and Russia which of the country
is concerned it's not just a history of
the Jews of the poles of the Ukrainians
are any people and is instead of history
of everyone who lives on a certain
territory as they are affected by these
two murderous regimes that seems very
simple but when you do that you were
able to keep all the victims in view
you're able to make your subject
humanity rather than this person or that
person or this group or that group now
it matters who people are
it matters to which group they belong
but if your subject is everyone that
gives you an entirely different view
than if your subject is one person or
one group also you get to see the
regime's I think in a more interesting
light normally books like this jump back
and forth in a way which is kind of
induces intellectual jet lag from Moscow
to Berlin one chapter Moscow the next
chapter Berlin by keeping my eyes of the
readers eyes on these territories I see
both Moscow and Berlin as they are in
action
I see the institutions the groups they
killed they send to these regions in
order to kill people or in order to
control people and that gives you a view
back through the institutions to Moscow
and Berlin but it's not this distinct
separate view of the two it's that's the
two regimes in action or sometimes in in
interaction I then follow all of the
policies that emerge whether they're
from the Soviet side or whether from the
German side it's all the same to me
whether the two sides are interacting
which they sometimes do or whether they
not that's also all the same to me I'm
just trying to observe and note what
each of the policies are so what does
that require well I've spent an awful
lot of time in East European archives
and some of the work on particular
policies does come from my own are
I will work but a lot of it comes from
taking the research of historians from
Israel or Germany or Russia or Ukraine
or Poland whatever it might be and
putting it together and trying to show
what they're trying to give a more
complete picture of each of the killing
policies whether it's the famine in
Ukraine or 1933 or whether it's the
Holocaust from 1941 to 1945 but also
trying to show how these policies fit
together as sometimes they did so this
means using an awful lot of languages it
also means opening oneself up to a lot
of different and often very competitive
discourses about what what happened back
then in the hope of fulfilling the
promise of all history which is that you
can tell us you can tell one sensible
story which brings in every perspective
and which is faithful to the facts okay
and in doing the research did you come
in did you come across anything that
really surprised you what was the most
surprising thing in writing the book
think yeah things surprised me all the
time that's that's what I would say
things I mean the book the book
surprises people one of you you you you
mentioned one of those yeah many people
have said things to me about this book
before they've read it to the effect
that oh I know sure book was gonna be
about no one has ever said that to me
after reading the book that is no one
has ever said this book was about what I
thought it was gonna be about or this
book said what I thought it was going to
be said what I thought I was going to
say and the reason for that is that so
much of what we think is actually so
constrained and so limited by the
national or by the ideological
perspectives so I was surprised all of
the time and I tried to make what
surprised me seem natural and plausible
to readers because I think in order to
rescue this in order to understand this
we have to have a completely different
perspective from the perspectives that
we have so my research was continual
surprising if it weren't for that sense
of surprise I wouldn't have felt that I
had to write the book one reason why I
felt I had to write the book was that
the scale the tragedy is just so great
another reason I felt I had to write the
book was because I thought that only an
Easter pianist would be able to do
something like this I think the Russian
estándar - have told us things that are
very important historians of Jewish life
with all those things that are very
important but only an Easter pianist is
going to be able to bring all these
different territories into the picture
and in mediate as it were
among all of these different
perspectives but it was the attempt to
try to make my own sense of surprise
about how little we know or how what we
hope how partial our knowledge is to try
to make to try to undo that to try to
reverse that that was one of the reasons
why I wrote the book so I can't really
point to any particular moment of
surprise I think one of the things which
came clear to me in writing this book
that is crucial is the the density of
suffering in certain places you
mentioned Ukraine Ukraine was the worst
place to be between 1933 and 1945 the
worst place to be in the Second World
War
41 to 45 39 to 45 was be others and no
one knows that I think that might be
something which I figured out early on
which continues to surprise people the
places our images of the war turned out
to be totally inadequate to the actual
suffering and the places where the
suffering was the worst Belarus are
almost totally alien to us so there's so
much rebalancing to be done and when you
say suffering and in reading the book
many people were starved to death versus
gassed or shot is that correct that's
right yeah so just complete and utter
lack of food yeah no that's a really
important point for a couple reasons one
of them is that it reminds us how
different that world was from our world
okay so you know you know I'm sure you
don't count calories I count calories
and and I count with the reason I count
calories is the reason you know right
German economic planners also counted
calories but not because they're worried
that people were going to be too fat
because they were worried literally
about having enough calories so that
oxen and mules and horses and cattle and
human beings working on farms or in
factories would have enough energy and
calories a unit of energy they were
concerned about food quite literally the
way we are concerned about energy if not
more so food was a way to imagine future
development for both the Nazis and for
the Soviets in the Soviet Union trying
to control Ukraine the place which was
very fertile was like trying to control
say Saudi Arabia or Iraq or more so
because this is a place which is within
your own country if you can control
those people you can control their soil
then you can induce
realize you can do what you want with
them you can do what you want with the
future that's the way Stalin thought and
when they don't seem to be doing what
you want you then take everything from
them and allow them to starve and this
is a extremely painful and this is the
second thing why this is worth stressing
to whites such a good point this is an
extremely horrible way to die it's so
horrible that in a way it's just flowed
away from our own accounts of these
things we understand I don't think we
really do but we think we understand
gassing we think we understand shooting
but what it's actually like to starve or
to make someone else starve to death it
really it's a really difficult thing to
describe it's been a lot of effort kind
trying to get that right and it is such
a central experience more people were
starved in Europe in the middle of the
20th century than were either shot or
gassed it was actually the leading
method of deliberately killing people
and both the Soviets and the Germans did
it on the scale of millions final
question conclusions what do you
conclude in your book what do I conclude
well that there's there's an overall
argument about the presence of two
different very different but competing
ideological visions of radical change
there's an overall argument about the
relevance of territory for the people
who live upon it and for the people who
wish to conquer it but and in the
conclusion I work my way through some of
what I take to be the misunderstandings
about the various individual policies
whether it's Soviet terror or Soviet
Famine German deliberate starvation the
Holocaust but where I take the reader I
try to take the reader in the conclusion
is where I begin the book namely with
what I take to be the fundamental task
of history as a humanity when dealing
with a subject like this so we started
with with the number of 14 million which
is a colossal number it's an
overwhelming number I think it's much
more than we can really process I don't
think we can process 1 million or 3
million or 6 million let alone 14
million and that 14 million is a kind of
inheritance it's what we have from
national socials and it's what we have
from Stalinism is what we have from
Hitler in Stalin's but we have from this
experience but the experience is so
horrifying that we don't have a way of
getting into it so where I return to in
the conclusion is the method not of
beginning from these huge numbers but if
we're beginning from trying to break the
big numbers down into smaller numbers in
the individual policies and then
breaking the individual policies down
into individual actions and not treating
the actions only from the point of view
of those who did the killing but trying
to understand also the lives up to the
moment when they are killed of the
people who will be murdered so that
insofar as we can we treat the
individual the victim not just the
victim but primarily the victim the
victim in the first place the victim as
an individual human being so that the
the pros of the book is a kind of effort
of recovery and that's a method you
asked about method earlier that's a
method that I'm taking the unit of
concern in the book as the individual
human life as opposed to an ideology or
a nation that's the unit of concern but
it's also the moral conclusion of the
book that we ought to try in my way of
trying to do it as history other people
have other ways but we ought to try to
turn these huge numbers back into people
one person at a time
insofar as we can okay thank you so much
for being here today and sharing some of
your work thank you for more information
about professor Snyder and his research
please visit our website at Yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale